what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 7th of june from the heart of new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings people always ask me joey why
do you like draftkings so much
i tell them easy and nice it's easy to
navigate and it has clear
instructions plus they got a million
ways that you would
get it on the action prop bets pools
casino fantasy whatever you're into it
they got it right now the basketball
players
playoffs are heating up last week i made
[__] a little bit of money
with atlanta over the [__] knicks i
made a little bit of money
with utah over [__] memphis you know
what i'm saying but now
it gets a little tougher we got brooklyn
against milwaukee
that started on friday night it's been
almost 10 years since the left
the nets left jersey and they might go
all the way this year
look at what uncle joey and draft kings
is doing for you
for the playoffs you could turn a dollar
into a hundred worth of site credit are
you listening to me
pick any basketball team that's still in
contention
better buck and if they win boom you get
credits to play around then you start
having real fun on draftkings i'm going
to be honest with you
i'm going to make a little video this
weekend of me [__] around i'll tell
you why
i'm having a great time on draftkings
when i started the account
i put 600 in there okay
i've been on that account i don't know
how long
and i still got 388 dollars on that
you know why because i'm not playing to
[__]
be johnny bananas i'm playing just to
have a good time i'm bored at night
i bet the under on the [__] lakers
the other night you know
[__] like that roll with the hundo into
another great promotions they have
on baseball hockey golf and tennis with
draftkings
let me tell you something you could even
bet on darts i was even looking for my
daughter's softball game on there the
other day
i gotta look a little deeper and [__]
plus they got
the casino and the fantasy all in one
wallet
i gotta tell you a quick fantasy story
don't tell nobody
when i first joined i was such an idiot
i didn't join
the uh draftking sports book app
i joined the [__] fantasy app guys
so i put a couple hundred bucks in there
i'll go over to dan florentine's house
i ask him why i can't bet he tells me i
put in the wrong [__] thing we got to
get the money out of there
i said you know what he goes you know
how hard it is to win these things
i i don't know so he goes pick a [__]
team
guys between me and you i didn't know
who one player was from the other all i
do know
is i went over on the budget
and i had to switch pitches and when i
switched pitches
i got to be on the [__] team okay
i forgot all about it three days later i
go back to
his house we're gonna download the
sports book app
we go to the [__] draftkings fantasy
i won a thousand dollars in the [__]
pool without knowing anything
so see what i'm saying you don't need to
know anything to win on [__]
draftkings that's the point
so you're gonna watch these basketball
games anyway why not make them
interesting
download the top-rated draftking sports
book app now
or the fantasy app use promo code joy
when you sign in
and turn a dollar into 103 credits
bet on the basketball team of your
choice to win their next game
when they do you claim 104 credits
that's a promo code joey for limited
time only a draftking sportsbook
but here's the fine print you got to be
21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
new customers only wager paid out and
site credits
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
[Music]
sportsbook for details if you got a
gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler in indiana call 1-809
with it but if everything's cool
download the drought king sports book
app now
or the draftkings fantasy app
and start winning some [__] guitars
if an idiot like me could pick a [__]
team
and win a geno can you imagine what you
could do you know all the fantasy
you know all the teams you know all the
players get your knowledge and start
making a little money
i'm not pushing you to be a [__]
degenerate but been 25 hours on a
[__] playoff game on a wednesday
night when nobody knows and nobody's
sitting there next to you
it's not a bad idea listen it's nba time
just go with the under they got to play
defense
that's your pick from uncle joey the
joint is also brought to you by
zip [__] recruiter let's just
call it zip recruiter they're a great
company
good help is hard to find it's like
trying to find
[__] you know god knows what it's
like trying to find a starbucks
in a [__] rural town you could always
post your job online
on a cork board at the laundromat good
luck
who goes to a laundromat people will do
their own laundry
then you gotta just sit there and hope
the right person walks by and sees it
again stop dreaming smack yourself in
the face
you wanna know what you need to do you
gotta to try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com joey again
ziprecruiter.com joey they do the work
for you with one click
your job gets sent to over 100 top job
sites
and here's where it gets freaky deaky
they're matching technology hooks you up
with the people with the skills and the
experience you need
get qualified candidates fast let them
play matchmakers for you so you don't
have to
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers
who use zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
2.3 million businesses have already used
zip recruiter why are you missing out
while other companies overwhelm you with
too many options
zip recruiter finds what you're looking
for
and they deliver the goods like judas
priests in 79
so right now you can try zip recruiter
for free with joy what are you talking
about it's monday morning
for free whether you've got five
employees or 200 employees
you can't do it all you need zip
recruiter
and it starts by you by going by
ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey let's get this party started we got
a lot to talk about
and the nba playoffs are heating up
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
june the [__] seventh i hope
you guys had a great weekend
i'm coming at you from the [__]
jersey compound direct
the weekend was tip top magoo
90 [__] degrees it's 90 going to be
90 today again
uh i know i got the sweatshirt what are
you going to switch on it's early
[__]
trust me in a little while i have my
little [__] karate chop shirt on aka
cops shirt you know the ones that they
arrest you in
the cops when they come to your house on
bad boys bad boys
yeah or i [__] have the [__] uh
wife beater whatever the [__] you want
to call it
i'll have it on later on but anyway it
was a great weekend
i usually don't
have i'm in the habit of [__] uh
answering emails online on a podcast
i've never really i what i usually do is
to be honest with you
as i combine a few emails from different
people that the same genre
applied to and i'll try to apply the
story that day
to fill that genre without them knowing
and a week later they'll hit me up going
jesus christ
you described exactly what i was feeling
i won't let them know
that i read what they were feeling from
an email i'll just flip it on them it's
just something that i've been doing for
years that
i when i read your emails i'm not
writing down
mental notes that you guys are asking me
like little questions maybe struggles
you're going through whether it's
patreon facebook
you know whatever i always look through
emails
and i answer as many as i can back
because i think that's a
gentlemanly thing to do
so this week i got an email that i uh
the guy's name is robert i won't tell
you his last name
but he uh it was a very long email at
first i looked at it and i go the balls
on this guy
but i tried you know i took i took speed
reading
and composition in high school so i
learned how to look for key
words and he said prison and um
losing faith and a couple things so i
said you know what
i'm about to go to bed let me read this
[__] email
and uh just see what he was talking
about and he said that he had been out
of prison for 90 days
uh he had done two years for a theft
of a checkbook and blah blah blah blah
he had never been in trouble before the
drugs let him there you know it was like
reading my own [__] biography you
know
he's clean now you know he just smokes
briefly he's got a job he's uh
he's engaged you know everything is
going great in his life
and uh you know when you get out of
prison
or when something traumatized has
happened in your life maybe you're in
the service or something
and everything is going well you're
always waiting for the other
[__] shoe to drop you're like
oh [__] things are going too [__]
well
the other shoe is going to drop or i'm
going to [__] up purposely
i'm gonna [__] up purposely because
you know i don't need the success of my
life like
where is this coming from trust me i was
the king of doing it and
robert i gotta tell you you know i know
how you feel right now
you think that the [__] walls are
gonna cave in
the cops forgot to [__] press a
charge on you
for jaywalking in 1983 you feel that
people are looking at you i remember for
months after i got out of prison
even when i was in the halfway house i
would go shopping
and i felt people looking at me and i
would feel
[__] terrible i would feel like [__]
you know
and you just plow through it you keep
your chin up
and you push to do the good job
to do better and better and trust me
you're gonna have slip-ups along the way
we always do did you guys watch the
ethan soupy podcast on joe rogan
it took him 20 years to accomplish a
diet
it took me 12 years to accomplish
this diet that is finally working for me
so it takes time you have to do
different chemistries different formulas
you know when people say to you i've
experimented with drugs well
i don't know what the [__] you're
talking about i've experimented with my
life
you experiment you you take a look back
every eight weeks
and you go you know what that's not
working it's not [__] working for me
it's it's working against what i'm
[__] trying to do
so and that's how i overcame those
felonious feelings and even though
i was still doing crimes i wasn't doing
felonies you know i was doing mine as
[__] you know
bringing back receipts and getting [__]
from kmart and receipt rentals and [__]
like that
after i got into comedy
i really was embarrassed by my felt
felonious
behavior and my felonious record
so the first five or six years i gotta
be honest with you i hid it from
everybody
i didn't discuss it i didn't talk about
it i didn't you know
it was just one of those things then in
uh when i went back to colorado i got
exposed at that [__] christmas party
at
[__] uh sprinkler auto sales
and then people were like uh you know we
remembered
you know people forget people have a
short memory you know 20 years ago
i'm not saying nothing bad mike tyson
raped somebody
it was a setup we all know it was a set
up years later
you know you ever hear tom segorre's
story on the [__] podcast
when he bumped into mike tyson he had a
circle of people around them
20 of them were women we have a short
memory as americans we forgive and
that's fine
so you know for me i i
forgave myself over time like the thing
that i was doing was i was getting into
something like getting into
comedy and i kept trying one thing i'm
learning about writing this book is
that from 1983
to 19 to 2021
i could look you in the eye and tell you
i never stopped [__] trying
like i always kept trying
yeah i fell on my face but i kept
[__] trying i would fall on my ass
but i kept trying
you know four steps forward one step
back i [__] get it
that's the way it is if you can't handle
it then don't go for it and [__] sit
in bed and
eat subway sandwiches till they find the
body you know i'm saying i don't know
what the [__] to tell you but
i do know that eventually i just felt
normal i didn't do
anything i didn't participate
in anything in a felonious way once i
was done with my time i was done with my
time
i didn't want to sign up for any
newsletters i didn't want to go to any
therapy groups of
of convicts crying of what they did to
them in there and what they expected and
what they didn't expect listen
the bottom line was i [__] up i did my
time and now it's time to start all over
again from the [__] new
and every six months i you know i get i
get [__] whacked
you know i was doing great in 1991 when
i got on stage
but what wasn't doing great was my home
life
and sure enough in the middle of
everything i'm starting comedy i'm happy
boom
i get hit with a [__] divorce papers
how do you think that knock that knocked
the wind out of my sails
did i quit comedy no that i [__] go
to a therapist no
i just knew i had to keep doing [__]
comedy and you know
roll with the punches and go broke and
hire attorneys
but throughout that whole thing i didn't
[__] stop doing comedy i didn't give
a [__] who's the [__] gonna stop you
when you [__] love something you know
so throughout time the felony thing wore
off i met tim allen like i told that
story earlier in the year and now i felt
i had the green light and comedy
and the felony i did not let the felony
define who the [__] i was
that's the most important thing i
refused to let that felony
define who the [__] i was yes i made a
mistake
yes i paid my dues to society but no
i was not going to wear it on my sleeve
and say oh i'm never going to get a job
doing this because i'm a fountain i'm
never going to get a job doing this
because i'm a felon you know right now
i'm doing the best i've done
in the last nine months i'm telling you
guys i don't know what the [__] happened
i had a talk on wednesday
of last week with rudy sarzo and duncan
trussell
two of the smartest [__] i know
in the world two guys
who are professionals at talking you off
a mountain
that talk you off a cliff i'm sorry
mountain who goes to the [__]
mountain
a [__] hiker then he gets lost and
they gotta send a helicopter looking for
the [__] hiker
and i gotta be happy when they find this
[__] [__] because they didn't bring
a [__] compass with him
he makes the four o'clock news found
hiker in the hills of jersey
go [__] yourself you should have left
them there and let the bears get them
next time you bring a compass
and some water [__] anyway i don't
even know what i was talking
i don't even know what the [__] i was
talking about so rudy so rudy and duncan
they called you know we were talking
back and forth and i
i asked duncan if he was doing comedy
and he said that
uh he tried and the club owners wanted
the club to charge this and this and he
goes you know what that's what i didn't
want anymore
i didn't want the [__] so i turned
it down so he goes now i i notice that
there's some
open mics in the area that i'm gonna
jump on
you know and uh i i explained to him my
concerns i go you know i'm moving
forward in a lot of
areas but the place i'm having the
hardest
area with to stand up and he's like
listen
you did the smartest thing you could do
you got your family out of there that's
enough
that's what you were supposed to do you
weren't supposed to sit there and wait
for somebody to kick down your family's
door for you to do stand up at the store
you did the right thing so i don't want
you to look back and whatever and i know
i did
everything there is solid but rudy even
added better to it
he said you know what your stand up
what people are tracked about your
podcast why people are attracted to you
just naturally on stages
because your heart your heart is not
considered a muscle anymore it's
considered an
organ that's why when they have heart
transplants
people experience feelings of the person
who gave them the heart before
because your heart has a mind of its own
and your heart lets your mind know
when it's time for different things and
you know what whether you guys agree
with it or not
it makes a lot of sense and he backed
the story
he said that when he was in ozzie
oswan's band
that was everything he ever wanted i
mean you think about it you're
a 24 year old [__] kid
you're hanging out with a skinny guitar
player who turned out to be one of the
greatest guitar players in the history
of the world
and all of a sudden you get an audition
for
ozzy osbourne who's coming off a nine
album run with one of the greatest bands
of all time and
and not only that you get the job you
get the job you put now
together you tour the tour is a success
they put together another round diary of
a madman
the tour was a success and in the middle
of the tour his best friend dies
and within a week they start to tour
with a replacement
but rudy said every time he looked over
he didn't see randy there and
and all of a sudden he lost his will and
he said that
he did the live arm with ozzie and it
was time to move
on there was no hard feelings he just
felt that
he didn't want to play the bass anymore
his rudy sarzo
doesn't want to play the bass anymore
you just achieved your biggest goal in
life
and you don't want to play the [__]
base anymore i said he took some time to
himself
he hung out with his family and one day
he got a
call from one of the guys from quiet
riot
to finish up an album and that they did
the album
and he goes the reason why i did the
album wasn't because they were stars
i did the album because while i went
down there to help him i fell in love
with the base again and i fell in love
with this and look
by falling in love and it came from
passion
the album went to be one of the biggest
selling albums of all
[__] time in the heavy metal genre so
this all starts with passion
i have a passion for doing podcasting i
love doing podcasting
i love making you guys laugh i love
making you guys cry
i love making you guys think i love
making you guys aware
of things that i'm going through maybe
you're going through and we're putting
them together
i love all this [__] you know uh
i booked a movie you know and uh
i had to put the audition on tape you
know for the last three months i've had
to put auditions on tape and they've
made me nervous
i got uncomfortable i was getting
migraine headaches
i don't want to do them and i said you
know what i could just tell them no
and here's the funny thing i got one
this week but i turned it down
because it was 209 a day i'm a real deal
i can't [__] be an actor for 209 a
day
then they want to take me off the charts
for 30 days that means i can't go
swimming with my daughter
i can't do nothing because i got to
shoot a movie and poughkeepsie
for 209 a day i need that and then at
the end of the day
nobody sees these [__] movies anyway
so i told them listen i don't want to
read for this
but if they want to make an offer and
give me a producer credit
uncle joey will show up that tip top and
go i'm the first one there
and the last one to leave you know i'm
saying you know me there's no games
uncle joey so i [__] uh
put an audition on tape last week as a
detective
how's that one for you i thought it was
a stretch
i did a couple things to make myself
look like a detective
it was one line god damn i could
remember it because that's been my
biggest problem
i can't remember dick thank god to mike
and thank god to a dear friend of mine
erica florentine
who i'm writing the book this she said i
could get a teleprompter
online mike find me one that you could
download
and now auditions are [__] tremendous
because i could [__] teleprompt it
was like the ad i did for [__]
uh blue blocks couple weeks ago they're
talking about scientific [__] and [__]
i'm up three days trying to memorize my
[__] it's done
it's done that mechanism left you know
and uh so now with the teleprompter i
could help when i had that audition
the line was easy enough listen i put
the audition on tape
about 10 days ago and i still know the
line so
it's an easy line it's something i would
say so i'm not surprised
i got the movie if i shoot i shoot this
friday so i should be getting a call
for wardrobe i'm gonna have to go into
the city and they're gonna have to dress
me up
like a detective and hopefully it goes
somewhere and if it doesn't
it was funny because i was talking to my
wife
and you know i was telling about
the feelings i had about
not wanting to get on stage right now
and just doing other things
and really concentrating on the book and
maybe focusing on the podcast and
getting a studio and all this [__]
and she goes you know i have a feeling
that you're going to start working in
new york a lot more
i think you're not giving it a chance
you've only been here a couple months
you just got this agent new york
i think it's gonna it'll open up for you
and [__]
you know what a couple weeks later i
started i got a [__]
uh you know uh whatever that's
a long auto audition you know i blew
that one i got another audition i blew
that one
i blew the godfather audition i blew
that one but i knew that it's this is
numbers guys
if you sweat after every [__]
audition you're gonna die plus it's on
tape
that's the reason from day one even as a
stand-up
i detested when people call you up and
say hey
send us a tape you know what go [__]
yourself you cannot get the full
patois of uncle joey without a [__]
with a tape if you're just going to see
me on stage
doing seven minutes of material you're
not gonna understand what i'm about i
want you to see me walk into the club
i want you to see me walk into the club
15 minutes early and how i cheat the
wait staff
and how i talk to the customers and how
i am in the green room whether i ever
show up with
20 [__] losers or just myself whether
i'm drinking
or i'm not drinking all these things
will determine whether you come back
and if you're going to judge me i don't
think you have the right
to judge me off a [__] tape but
because of covid
and the whole thing they're doing
auditions off tape
i got the longest yard off tape in 2004
so i know that tape works it's just
sometimes
it doesn't it's like zoom you know but
you do the best you can you get better
at it i put this audition on tape
friday night at 10 44 i was sitting
downstairs with my wife
watching the mayor of edentown with my
[__] girl from the titanic
and the next thing you know i got a
[__] message
that i was in the running for the role
and i asked my agent what it meant
and he goes you probably got it and i
got to tell you something
i was kind of happy i do want a little
acting
thing i always thought about junior
soprano how he got that job
later on in his life that turned out to
be the role of his [__] life
i'm waiting for a fastball like that you
know
like i said i'm sure after the soprano
movie comes out
i'll do a little stand-up and whatnot
and have a good time locally but
you know i don't know i don't know right
now the future
is uncertain but the end is always near
let it roll baby roll
you know right now in my life i feel uh
the biggest adjustment i've had to make
the last
nine months has been my new role
you know my new role of not traveling
being around a lot more helping my wife
with the child
focusing on patreon trying to open up
different avenues whether it was the
book or whatever
but at times i felt guilty and i said
this a couple weeks ago on a podcast
i don't know what episode it was i felt
like i'm always living a lie
i'm living a lie that uh right now i
should have either been dead
or in prison but that's not the case
i'm here with a little girl and a wife
who i i get along great with
in less than 30 days we're about to be
be together for 21 years
you look at a guy like me like who can
hang out with you for 21 minutes
but i i don't know i got a girl to fall
in love with me and i fell in love with
her
and that's what it is you know but i'll
tell you a story and then we'll wrap it
up i know
you guys [__] to do on a [__]
monday morning so
i uh when i first got into comedy it was
july of 81
july 16th that's when we're launching
the new coco motion weed
from ice cream shop so i'll keep you
guys posted on that
and that's when the 30 anniversary nft
will also be coming out i'll keep you
posted
on that that's the type of [__]
i am you know what i'm saying
and uh we got a lot of things happening
in july we got a lot of things
happening in june we got a soprano movie
coming out in august uh september
i'm gonna try to get my patreon people
to maybe get a theater somewhere
close by and we could all do a screening
no pictures no nothing just watch the
[__] movie
shut your mouth and we'll do a q a
afterward we'll goof around
i'll let you smell one of my farts and
everybody goes home [__] happy i'm
just
listen guys i'm just going working
outside the box here
but i'm going to tell you why i'm the
luckiest i've ever am because
when i started comedy right before i
started comedy that january
i was living in boulder i was a host at
a car wash
i was there on a sunday i had a wife
i had a baby girl at the house
my daughter had to be around a year at
the at that time
and i was working the host window what's
a host window people pull up and you're
like hey how you doing
what type of wash do you want for your
car today and they're like oh we want
the regular you're like yeah but you got
rims
you gotta wash the rims but plus it's
snow two inches last week
you want to add some undercoating and
they're like yeah how much four dollars
sixteen dollars here listen i'll tell
you what i'll throw it in for 18
and i'll throw the whole [__] thing
in you know uncle joey you know what i'm
saying
always wheeling and dealing always
trying to make a commission i would sell
them i would always sell high commission
stuff
but give them the low commission stuff
for free and they felt good about
themselves i'll
do the windows i arm all the tires
so i'm doing this [__] gig
and somewhere along the line blah blah
blah bob
i get into comedy and i quit the job
and everything is going great in my life
and one sunday i'm working at this car
wash and this family comes in and they
have
an air freshener that has a cuban
[__] flag on it
and at that time in 1991
i had just done some time i was living
in san francisco
i had lived in colorado and the last
thing i had seen in months
was a cuban person i always
take you know i run away welcome them
and i go
and they looked at me like yeah like
they had been
looking for a cuban also they were out
there surrounded with [__] gentiles
so they're like yeah and we start
talking we just moved from miami
we've been here about six months we own
a company blah blah blah blah blah blah
so i said you know i gave the works for
like five bucks and i go get out of the
car and we'll talk and
we talked with mr dad the mom
the daughter her husband
the brother-in-law and
the and the other brother-in-law he at
the time
he had to be around 10. very [__]
nice family
you know we chatted for about 20 minutes
that car was ready they gave me a tip
and then they invited me over they said
with super bowl sunday do you want to
swing by
they told me where they lived and i go
wait a second i live right there too i
live
eight doors down oh [__] all right come
by
so boom i went by there and i i met the
the family and they cooked for me and
they were very nice
and i gotta tell you it felt great to be
around the cuban family it just
felt great for the afternoon and i went
back and at that time me and my wife
weren't you know i'm the best she
thought i was over there doing [__]
kilo
deals and stuff and i'm just over there
just meeting new people you know
so little by little we became friends me
and her and
the family and one day i tried to put
the families together and
my ex-wife was too starting to get
uppity by then and
you know i don't want to hang with
spanish people they're like a little
low-class
whatever they were they were but they
were very proud
they worked hard every day and they were
just great people they give you the
[__] [__] off their back
so we break up
you know and who comes to my [__]
corner
but these cuban people you know i didn't
even have silverware she came over and
gave me silverware and
would invite me off for dinner every
night and you know pretty soon
i was just a regular member of the
family i would go over there every night
but she had two younger brothers
and the one brother was in high school
he was a
great baseball player with great
potential
but the medium brother was a little bit
of bots he was
if i was this is
91 so i'm 28. he had to be around 23.
i knew there was a problem because he
was uh
ice ice baby fan he
loved vanilla ice he thought vanilla ice
was jimmy page
he would argue with you that vanilla ice
was a better writer than john lennon
i mean it was surreal
like he thought vanilla ice was better
than prince
i mean he was just on a different planet
but he also loved that song uh
uh rico suave so you got to take this
with a grain of salt yeah
the guy had a natural bad taste for
[__] music
i wasn't angry with him but the younger
brother had a reputation as a klepto
he had clipped uh
you know the brother-in-law danny who
was a great guy would get them little
jobs
and after a while i ended up getting the
impression that
danny had gotten him like four jobs and
he had gotten fired from all four of
them
for doing stupid [__] taking like a
flashlight
you know
it's december 18th 1991 and i'm headed
to
the finals of the broker joker
competition
i'm doing comedy six months and here i
am in the finals of a national
competition
we at that time every tuesday that i
performed
the defeat that danny and his wife
would hire a babysitter they would get
the [__] brother
ice i say baby to watch my nephew junior
and they would come to the show
and cheer me on and we would have a
couple drinks
do a couple lines you know same [__] no
big deal
well this december 18th this is a
special night for me
i mean it's really [__] special i'm
i'm
separated i miss my daughter
i have no job i lost my job and
[Music]
the thing i wanted the most is is
happening i'm in a [__] national
contest you know wow
jesus christ i should be ecstatic and i
was
and i went down and there was a little
drama that i spoke about before
about the fight out of gas money and
once we overcame that
i went up there and ripped the [__]
room apart and won the [__] finals
we party you know till about one in the
morning
we're doing bumps we know we don't have
a lot of money but we're doing a couple
bumps we're drinking
we're getting free drinks from the
broker and when we go back
we go let's just go back to danny's and
finish off the package
but as we pull up there's three cop cars
now it's december 18th of 1991.
we go inside uh the cops are there do
you people live here yes we do we're all
coked up
the cocaine high jumps out of you you
ever been coked up
you've been high and the doorbell rings
and it's the ups
man and you open up the door and the
high just jumps out of you
and it stands next to you in the corner
and it goes you're on your own
you know what i'm saying you're in that
position so the [__] kokai just
jumped out of us
and we're like what's going on we
thought they were there for me for the
child support
you know whatever my wife would have
told them no they were there
because uh ice ice baby
decided he had a job at kentucky fried
chicken
and he decided to steal the manager's
suitcase
with the codes to the safe and all this
[__] there was some cash
in there so they take them in they
arrest them
and uh
i think we bailed them out within two or
three days
it's the the holidays passed
i think after the holidays he robbed
his brother-in-law's partner
he robbed his house and
he got a spank in the hand for that we
had to apologize to the kid
but then he went to a different company
that he knew his brother-in-law was
friends with
he applied for the job and he stole the
van
and that was it that created an event
you know he couldn't get bail
he stayed in there and so on and so
forth
you know this story by heart already you
know
93 i moved to [__]
jersey i came back in ninth
october of 93. where's this
he's still in [__] jail you know 95
where's this he's getting out of jail 95
he got out
he hooked up with some chubby chick he
impregnated her he robbed the car
and he went back into [__] jail and
then i left colorado but i kept
in touch with this family because all
those years
they were very good to me they were on
my side
uh one of my toughest situations they
lent me their cars
i had my daughter's birthday parties at
their house
they were just a great family and they
were there for me so i kept in touch
with them
over the years at the end of every
conversation
i would ask about ish and they would say
oh he's either still in jail
or he's out with another girl he knocked
her up
he was just coming out of jail knocking
up [__]
and getting arrested well this went on
till about
2013. he got out and
finally danny got him another job
against his best [__]
whatever and uh he pregnant another girl
and he [__] uh
got arrested again and you know
nobody heard from him he was in the
system and
this is how life goes and now it's 2121.
dear damn driving here it's a beautiful
day to be alive
i usually lift and then i do a little
walk therapy
so i said let me go for a little walk
therapy and
the phone rang and it was junior and we
started talking and i go hey i had a
coincidence
how's [__] ishmael doing he goes
you're not going to believe it
the state of colorado is going to parole
him
within the next two weeks on one
condition
that he leaves colorado they want them
to
they're going to parole him to florida
they're even going to buy him a plane
ticket he can never step foot again in
colorado
and they go it's me uh junior i go you
know what's crazy about that
but it's 30 years
this whole ordeal started december 18th
of 91 and this kid is going home
let's assume july of 2011.
it's been 30 years so when i look at my
life and i say to myself jesus christ
i'm so lucky for being here that i ended
up with a house instead of being in
prison
or in jail i think of that kid
and i think about how he's going to come
out of prison now
the age of 50. he's gonna be in miami
i don't have to tell you what type of
city miami is it's rough and [__]
tumble
and uh with all the no disrespect i
don't want to
end up in the front page of yahoo or
whatever but
with all the [__] you know immigrants
down there the high-end
immigrants it's tough to get a job if
you're really really looking you know
and
uh i just can't imagine
being eight years younger you know at 50
i had mercy
i can't believe but 50 i would have to
start my life
up again so thinking about that story
the other day when junior
called me over the weekend really made
me think
how fortunate i am that
i was in the same position at ish at
some time
and today here i am and today and i'm
not putting them down and i'm not
judging
i'm just letting you know how my life
could have gone
instead of the way i have it today and
why i'm grateful to you guys
and where i'm happy i'm here and every
monday and wednesday
sometimes i show up with a guest
sometimes i've got
i'm solo but sometimes i just want to
tell you something maybe a little story
to help you out on the monday morning
and that's what i did today on a
beautiful
beautiful june 7th i get i think she's
got 11 days left of school
then the summer starts we're going down
the shore once a week you know
we got the swim club we got the whole
thing i found out the [__] pool's not
heated
so if you see me and i look like an
eskimo don't worry about it
it's that the pool's not heated but you
know what
i'm all set and ready to go and it's
monday morning this is gonna be the best
week of your life
and uh that's it and that's that i
i'm happy you took the [__] 45
minutes
to listen to my [__] ear
beating if you want more you could also
join me on patreon
i do a couple podcasts on there and
the nfts get released on the 16th
it doesn't guarantee that you get one i
only release
200 and whether you want when you buy
one if you don't you have to buy one
don't ask me joy what an nft is google
it
and get into the bitcoin world and do
whatever the [__] you need
to [__] do to get you ahead of the
[__] game
i see that already from the may release
some people have made money on bitcoin
not one of you has thanked me you dirty
[__]
but don't worry about it i did it but i
don't i don't need thanks from you guys
i i wanted you to make a little money
and enjoy yourself with the [__]
cards and uh
just being a part of the future is great
when you're
50 old and you're 58 years old and you
got one foot in the grave won a banana
peel but remember
i'm always your uncle joey and that's
all that [__] matters to the end
i love you [__] see you wednesday
tip top magoo with a guest
and i'm happy you listen today all right
and now
for a [__] word from our
sponsors [__]
let's do this all right i want to thank
you guys for listening today today was a
short quick one
i don't want to take a lot of your time
up we got plenty of time all summer to
talk [__]
i got plenty of new things happening so
like i said get ready a [__] rock but
before we abandon ship the joint is
brought to you by
zip recruiter listen good help is hard
to find
it's like trying to find a nickel bag in
church you know what i'm saying you're
not gonna find
it you can post your job online or on a
cork board down the laundry mat but then
you gotta sit there and hope some guy
walks by that drinks coffee and sits
there
and watches it stop dreaming just try
zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com joey
they do the work for you with one click
your job gets sent to over 100 job sites
and here's where it's get freaky dekey
where's rick james
that technology hooks you up with people
with skills and experience that you need
get qualified candidates
fast let them play matchmaker for you
so you don't have to whether your
business whether you have four business
business people
four employees i'm sorry or 200
employees
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers use zip recruiter
to get a quality candidate within the
first day
and i'm not kidding you 2.3 million
businesses
have already used ziprecruiter why are
you sitting there like a bump on a log
scratching your head reading from resume
to resume like a dozen bots
knock it off while other companies
overwhelm you with too many options
zip recruiter finds exactly what you're
looking for
the needle in the haystack and you know
what they find it quick
within two or three days you got your
quality candidate
and your job and your career and your
business moves on
you don't get there anybody anywhere
else and right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free joy
what do you mean free
gratis on the arm ziprecruiter.com
joey it works that's ziprecruiter.com
joey listen from the heart of new jersey
one of new jersey's favorite businesses
why i
teamed up with them and why i love them
his draftkings
joy why do you love draftkings so much
because it's not just about [__]
being an [__] and gambling and trying
to be a winner
they make it fun like if you join up
every day you get an email at some point
of the day
do you think stefan whatever will make a
three point a better dollar and win 18
what you don't need eighteen dollars gas
is five dollars a gallon [__]
who are you kidding plus they got a
million ways to you to get it on the
action
prop bets pools casino fantasy whatever
you're into
they [__] got it you understand me
basketball players are heating up the
first round is over
the knicks went the [__] south the
lakers went south
uh look lebron james went into the
locker room crying
i bet he bet himself like pete rose he's
over there hugging pete after the game
right now you got brooklyn and milwaukee
that series started friday
and the games are going to be epic it's
been almost 10 years
since the la nets left jersey and they
might as well go all the way this year
that's what people are looking for
but you never seen a bookie with a
part-time job look at what uncle joey
and draftkings are doing for you this
week
we're doing the for the playoffs you can
turn a dollar
into 100 hours worth of site credit how
joey
pick any basketball game that's still in
contention
better buck and if they win boom you got
a hundred dollars in sight credits to
play around with
then start having real fun on draftkings
that's when the fun starts
because you can switch it up over to the
casino they have great casino things
like this week if you bet 50 dollars on
the game three nights in a row they gave
you a free 25
credit come on what are you gonna get
that at plus the casino and the fantasy
all in one wallet come on draftking
sportsbook is safe
secure reliable deposit and withdraw
your funds
at your convenience you're watching the
game anyway
you're gonna sit there it's on cnn uh
tnn whatever the [__] it is why make
it not interesting right you bet the
over
you up you you pray for them to score
it's the playoffs they play a little bit
of defense so the under has been coming
in
i had the lakers in the end i think uh
the other night
so have some fun i'm not talking you to
get
go crazy or be a degenerate you better
what you got
twenty dollars boom boom boom and there
you go
so download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app or the fantasy app
use promo code joey when you sign up to
turn a dollar
into a hundred and free credits bet on
basketball team of your choice
whether it be i don't even know i think
the celtics got eliminated that's why
milwaukee is playing the celtics
you got utah you got i know you got
denver yeah you got some great teams
left
and this is the week to do it use promo
code joey
for limited time only a draftking sports
book
here's the fine print you got to be 21
older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
only
new customers still apply wager paid out
and psych credits again you got to be 21
years old to go get the skateboard
go do something go get ice cream with
your friends and talk about [__] some
game on
on itunes or something you're driving me
crazy young [__] suckers
why can't i go on draftkings because you
don't even have hair on your dick
see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details now if you got a gaming poem
i don't want you to bring your [__]
bad luck over the draftkings keep it
somewhere else
call one eight hundred gambler or in
indiana call
one eight hundred nine with it now if
you're not got no problems
and you know how to control your
emotions and you're not a [__] gavon
download the draftking sportsbook out
now and let's win some [__] guitars
all right
i love you [__] stay black have
a great weekend i want to thank the
joint
and i want to thank zip recruiter for
having our back what great weekend
let's have a great week we're just going
to kick off the week with nothing but
love
heart and enthusiasm i love your [__]
suckers
i'll see you wednesday morning tip top
magoo
ready to [__] go will i be high by
then
who knows i don't have a fortune ball no
more
i got the two swinging between my legs
have a great [__] week enjoy your
monday
oh yeah
there you go puff the magic candle [__]
[Music]
suckers
you